hey you guys flickers of fear time and
we're continuing on with giallo july
this is the penultimate
installment of geolo july and today
we're going to be talking about
umberto lindsay
now uh umberto lindsay if you're a fan
of italian horror um italian gore films
in particular then that name should be
very familiar to you he was uh the man
responsible for such infamous cannibal
flicks as man from deep river which i
think was actually the first italian
cannibal flick if i'm not mistaken uh he
also made eaton alive and cannibal ferox
one of the video nasties
but he also directed a number of jello
films uh including eyeball uh so sweet
so perverse seven bloodstained orchids
which i've seen and is actually very
good and the film we're discussing today
which is called knife of ice now in
spite of lindsay's uh pedigree
vis-a-vis his cannibal cycle i guess if
you want to call it that
and also in spite of the fact that knife
of ice stars carol baker who was
actually in three of lindsay's previous
giallo movies which were just stuffed to
the gills with sex and violence this one
is actually surprisingly restrained and
though i liked it quite a bit um if
you're looking for buckets of blood and
big beautiful heaving bouncing boobies
then you had better look elsewhere
because you will be sorely sorely
disappointed this one is just very very
very conservative so knife of ice
actually took its inspiration from the
1946 horror movie the spiral staircase
uh lindsay was initially going to do a
remake of that uh starring carol baker
but in the end i don't know if he
couldn't get the rights or if he just
decided hey i'm just gonna do like my
own original story which is just kind of
like take some ideas from that the main
idea being that the main character is
going to be a mute woman who's stalked
by a killer the title of the film
incidentally is taken from a quote which
is attributed to edgar allan poe not
sure if it was actually a quote from him
or not but the quote is fear is a knife
of ice which penetrates the senses down
to the depth of conscience
and though the murderer does use a knife
and uh presumably there's some fear
generated thereby
at no point does anyone use a knife
that's actually made of ice so you know
just trying to manage expectations
uh again incidentally this film also
gets compared quite often to lucio
fulchi's don't torture a duckling which
also came out in 1972. same as this
movie now please note
those of you who are sensitive to animal
violence such as me
i wish somebody had told me this ahead
of time but but nobody did i had to find
out the hard way uh please note that the
very first shots of the film the very
opening sequence like with the credits
and everything like that are of an
actual bull fight uh in which the bull
gets killed so again if you're very
sensitive to real animal cruelty uh you
might want to skip ahead till after the
credits uh but there are some scenes uh
of this bull fight that turn up in
flashback like briefly later on in the
movie uh so fair warning
also and this is
man this is like something that i
complain about a lot there is also a
sweet kitty cat that occurs that appears
like early on the film
so you know how that's gonna go uh yeah
that death isn't real i hope uh but it's
still upsetting because you know how i
am about kitties leave the damn animals
alone in italy god damn it well actually
now it's just kind of like every time
you see a cat or a dog in a horror movie
i'm just like well they're done for i
don't know if i want to watch this or
not because it's almost become like this
edgy thing i don't know i guess because
we're also
uh horror fans are just so ignored to
seeing people getting killed so it's
like we're gonna kill fido that's why
everyone's gonna be mad about that so i
was just like knock it off they didn't
they didn't deserve it just kill the
people i don't care so carol baker plays
martha and she's a young woman who's
actually been completely mute since she
saw her parents die in a horrible fiery
train wreck when she was just a little
girl i guess like her dad like chucked
her out the train window which is
actually kind of
comical but sort of like horrific at the
same time so she like escaped the flames
but her parents did not so they were in
there and they burned to death and she
saw the whole thing happening so she
hasn't talked since then now she does
seem to be managing all right though uh
she lives with her uncle ralph and a
couple of servants at this very pleasant
estate up in the spanish pyrenees and
she also has a kindly family physician
named dr laurent who seems to be taking
care of her now her uncle ralph has a
heart condition
and so he needs to be like he's okay
he's still pretty spry like he walks
around and stuff he's a scholar of some
kind and but he has to kind of be like
have bed rest sometimes and he's on all
this medication which you know martha
seems to be more than capable of like
taking care of him and everybody just
seems to think martha is the bee's knees
like she's just the best kindest
loveliest person ever now at the
beginning of the movie martha's sister
jenny arrives for a visit
now jenny is apparently kind of like a
famous singer i don't really know what
kind of singer she is it was like opera
or it wasn't opera exactly i'm not
really sure what it was but she's like
kind of a famous singer and she's been
touring north america and she's talking
about how you know successful the tour
has been so she arrives by train and
martha is very very proud of herself for
being able to meet her sister at the
train station which obviously uh she had
traumas about going to a train station
because of the [ __ ] that happened to her
parents uh so she had never been able to
go to train station before so she's like
super excited she's making some progress
you know she actually went to the train
station pick her sister up now jenny
comes there uh bearing gifts she
actually has a pile of books on the
occult which she's going to give to
uncle ralph who studies that kind of
thing which against
it's one of the things that's supposed
to make him seem suspicious because this
this is a giant movie so everybody has
to have like red hairing stuff everybody
has to seem sketchy so that's his
sketchy thing uh and she also brings
this old audio recording like a
real-to-real tape type situation that's
like a recording of martha as a child
reciting the lewis carroll poem the
mouse's tale and this was obviously
before the accident uh where you know
martha lost her voice where she couldn't
talk anymore now while the two women are
being driven back to the house a very
strange incident occurs
whereby this dude with these bizarre
kind of cloudy speckly something like
looking eyes
kind of comes out of the fog this is a
very foggy movie by the way um so just
know that going in like not all of it
but a lot of it's like really foggy so
he comes out of the fog and like looks
at them through the car window and then
disappears again
uh it's weird because i think this is
maybe like the third or fourth giallo
movie i've watched recently that had
like somebody wearing weird contact
lenses like as a plot point so i'm
guessing that maybe
these weird contact lenses like because
remember i was talking about the ones
that were like people with bright blue
contact lenses and [ __ ] like that like
the last couple i talked about um this
must have been like a new thing like
these weird-looking contact lenses like
that were easy to wear so i'm guessing
that's why they inserted them and like
so many movies because it's like oh it's
this new cool thing but yeah they're in
this one too so it must have been like a
big trend in italy in the early 1970s
now the night that jenny arrives at the
house the household hosts a birthday
party for uh the 13 year old i guess
she's like a neighbor girl or i don't
remember if she's like an orphan or
something like that but her name's
christina and she's actually like a
close friend of martha's i don't know if
mar is martha like maybe
tutoring her i don't remember i said
something like that
they just say it's almost kind of like
you know like a mother-daughter
situation so i'm guessing like the
little girl doesn't have parents i don't
know so i think they mentioned it but i
can't remember
now at the party we are introduced to
most of our main characters uh you know
or suspects if you prefer because that's
essentially what they are uh including
the aforementioned dr laurent there's a
local priest named father martin
this very shifty ass chauffeur named
marcos and the two housekeepers one of
whom is named annie and one of whom is
named rosalie
now later that night after all the
guests have presumably gone home
jenny wakes up because she hears
something breaking downstairs so she
creeps down there to investigate and
finds the door to the garage like from
the house to the garage like wide open
now unwisely because she should know
that she's in a giallo movie and this is
never a good thing to do if you're in a
giant movie she goes into the garage to
check it out because she hears like a
noise in there and she's like why is
this door open
and uh it will surprise no one to know
that she ends up on the wrong end of a
knife now when her body is found
underneath the car the next morning
the cops are naturally summoned to deal
with it and everybody in the household
is questioned
the two guys that the movie leans
hardest into making you suspect
immediately are marcos who frankly
always acts superstars like just
whatever he always he looks a little bit
like boris karloff so i think they just
like because i was like the first time i
saw him was like man look at that boar's
car left looking [ __ ] but yeah
he does actually look a lot like boris
cause he kind of acts like he's very
very shifty uh and dr laurent now his
thing was he claims that he left the
party then he's like oh i got a couple
minutes away remember i left my medical
bag behind and i came back to the house
to get it but because the house was all
locked up and all the lights were out um
i didn't want to disturb anybody like
wake him up by knocking to get my bag
back so i left again not so fast says
marcos the shifty boris karloff looking
[ __ ] he tells police that dr
laurent uh that he saw dr laurent
standing by his car in the driveway and
that he was signaling up to annie one of
the housekeepers who was leaning out her
bedroom window so he says there was a
light on in the house it was annie's and
he's like so that was a lie that you
came back and nobody was awake he's like
i saw you signaling now both dr laurent
and annie deny that this happened
but
you know i this is put in here so the
viewer is clearly supposed to find dr
laurent's movements like sketchy as the
fact that he went back to the house to
fetch his bag placed him uh at the scene
of jenny's murder at the approximate
time that it happened like between 11 30
and midnight or whatever it was his
medical bag though it should be noted uh
was actually still by the front door
just like he said it would be he's like
yeah i think i left it by the front door
because i was like walking out and i
left it there so the police do find it
there so he's like okay well that checks
out now at the end of the interrogation
after they've you know
brought up like suspicions about several
of the people
the detectives actually kind of surprise
everybody by saying well actually we
think that this murder was committed by
this random sex maniac uh because
another woman with blonde hair was
actually found dead in a ditch not too
far from this house this woman is i
don't think she's ever named
now at jenny's funeral martha sees the
guy with the weird contact lenses
peering at her like through the bushes
and she you know says to the other well
she doesn't say because she can't talk
but you know she gestures to the other
she's like hey that guy's over there uh
so all the other people at the at the
funeral like the doctor and everything
like that they run after the guy now the
guy escapes but he's dropped like a
pendant that has uh a goat's head on it
so this leads investigators to think
obviously that the murder is a satanist
so they're like okay well
they theorized that the killer
maybe uh is targeting young blonde women
because jenny was also young and blonde
uh you know for sacrifice so they advise
martha who is also blonde uh that she
should be probably on the lookout to
ensure that she is not the next victim
the next one on the chopping block
though isn't martha but is actually the
dark-haired housekeeper annie
who one day goes into town on her
bicycle to do some shopping
spots a goat's head symbol like painted
in red on a tree trunk she goes unwisely
again to investigate and gets murdered
like gets her throat slashed
shortly after this dr laurent arrives at
martha's house and has a bit of blood or
perhaps red paint on his pants now he
explains this the way it's like oh
that's was one of my patients like he
had some [ __ ] happening like he sprayed
a little bit of blood on me i didn't
notice because the movie is trying so
hard to make you think dr laurent is the
killer you just know by laws of giallo
logic that it's absolutely not him you
know what i mean that's what i'm saying
i'm just like
just dial it back a little bit because
like that's obviously not who it is it's
never the most obvious person ever even
though it should be said that he does
also conveniently forget something else
after the little girl christina uh
actually becomes the final casualty of
the slasher now at some point the
satanist guy with the with the weird
contact lenses is also apprehended and
it turns out that he's just like this
morphine addicted british hippie who is
absolutely a satanist but he mostly just
likes he's not sacrificing anybody he
just basically likes to do black masses
and abandoned buildings and stuff like
you know
well don't we all don't we i'm sure
no but but yeah so the whole angle about
like the satanic serial killer and the
unnamed woman who was found in the ditch
uh even though a lot of screen time is
devoted to it actually just kind of
serves as the film's biggest red herring
matter of fact uh this film in
particular though it did manage to throw
me off effectively a few times like
later on
telegraphs who the murderer is fairly
early on at least if you're paying
attention so even though i was slightly
surprised by i think like the way it was
revealed because they did a couple
things i didn't expect i have to say i
wasn't all that shocked by the big twist
at the end and uh like i said i think if
you're paying attention you probably
won't be either i don't know it's like
hard for me to say
uh that said i still did have a pretty
good time with this one even though i
think like the final revelation wasn't
quite the bombshell that it was
apparently meant to be because i kind of
saw it coming but there were some things
that i didn't see coming so you know so
as i mentioned this is a pretty
serviceable uh jala movie all the
standard murder mystery tropes uh you
know you got your rogues gallery of
possible suspects there's some fun
twists and turns in there there is
absolutely no sex or nudity uh and it's
not gory in the slightest other than the
bull fighting stuff uh all the murders
essentially occur off screen you don't
really see a lot of it happen um you
know sometimes you see the aftermath but
it's not even bloody i don't even
remember hardly any blood in it at all
or even any of the kind of like operatic
or super violent like stabbing there's
nothing like that it's basically just
kind of like hey here's a knife here's
the woman's face she's screaming and
then you cut to the next scene so
there's hardly any blood in it at all
but it was still like entertaining
enough to hold my attention though i
will admit that it seemed a little bit
buttoned up in places i guess like i
said it's a very conservative giallo in
the sense that you know it's just very
much a parlor murder mystery type thing
with no
there's no sleaze element to it it's not
sleazy in the slightest now carol baker
i have to say was great as martha um she
was able to convey a lot of emotion like
just with her face as obviously she
doesn't say a single word throughout the
entire film so that was great uh you
know like i said the resolution the
mystery is pretty obvious from the
get-go
but i mean all the little by ways that
the movie went down to try to lead you
away from who the killer actually was
were pretty enjoyable diversion so i'm
not going to complain too much
in terms of jlo movies um it was you
know nothing to write home about but
it's still a decent watch if you're more
into the more you know murder mystery
angle and not so much the sex and
violence angle because like i said this
one really doesn't have either of those
two things so that will do it for this
installment of geolo july on flickers of
fear we're gonna do one more before the
end of the month so hopefully you'll
tune in for that one and that'll do it
for today i will see you guys on the
next one
bye